appdev analytics security and so much
more on this weekend cloud where we
bring you the lowest latency news google
cloud next was crazy this year with lots
of announcements so let's get started
first up the latest launch is an app dev
anthos was launched which helps you span
across hybrid or multi cloud
environments with your services using
kubernetes through google kubernetes
engine and gke on prem you'll have a
standard way to deploy services with
built in policy and security automation
plus unified monitoring and to help
support automation across hybrid
workloads cloud run was also announced
which enables developers to run server
list containers in a fully managed
fashion on GCP on gke or on-premises in
the world of data basis and analytics
what are our most exciting announcements
was bigquery BI engine which allows you
to do first-class bi in data studio our
dashboarding and reporting tool you can
now use a super fast in memory analysis
service for big free to analyze large
and complex datasets interactively all
with sub second query response time and
high concurrency analysts can perform
speed of thought data exploration on
their latest data via data studio and
Google sheets plus clouds equal just
added support for a new database type
managed sequel server a fully managed
service for sequel server both built-in
performance scalability and security so
you can focus on your applications on
the data management front our data
fusion launch provides a fully managed
code free data integration service that
helps you move data and then process and
land that data within GCP and we can't
forget about the exciting announcements
in machine learning auto ml tables was
launched which enables you to
automatically build models on arbitrary
tables of data like bigquery tables or
CSV now data scientists analysts and
developers can automatically build and
deploy state-of-the-art machine learning
models on structured data at a massively
increased speed and scale we've also
announced incredible launches in
security our Cloud Security Command
Center 1ga is a single centralized
dashboard that helps security teams
gather data identify threats and act on
them before they result in business
damage or loss and with event threat
detection it can detect suspicious
activity from stacked driver logs and
then flags them for remediation
the threats will be surfaced in cloud
security command center if you want to
read more about these announcements or
see a full list check out the link half
thoughts or ideas leave us a comment or
tweet us we'll see you in the cloud